if you could have one professional
athlete join your team right now any
sport who would it be greatest
basketball player of all time LeBron
LeBron James LeBron where are you
putting in tight end I'm put him offense
and defense I probably put him in tight
end or receiver maybe Flex him out as
much as possible and then on defense I
might put him in like D or something go
with the king I got to go LeBron LeBron
is prime let him play a little tight end
wide receiver whatever it takes you want
LeBron obviously where are you putting
him tight end LeBron we can play it all
probably I tell LeBron to come on down
get right with us you know he got his
background in football position is he
playing I say re put LeBron just on the
outside for a jump ball when everyone
said LeBron put him at tight end yeah
yeah we could do that too killer combo
right there